One of the foods with many nutrients filled with protein, minerals and vitamins.
Small elements, so it seems, but of big daily means for your body.
They give you energy and assist your resistance to function properly.
Of course, cheese naturally contains fat,...
...but your body needs vitamins and energy precisely from that.
Enjoy consciously the many, many ways of sensational smell and taste.
Cheese on bread, brown white spelt, healthy sandwiches and tuna melt.
Cheese fondue and Swiss raclette, croissant au fromage, breakfast in bed.
Cheese platter, onion soup, veggie quiche and lots of mac and cheese.
So many types and majorities.
Perfect for everyday situations, yet special for social occasions.
Here we are, from milk to mouth, and that's what makes the circle round.